plus de 7000 m² entièrement dédié à la
mobilité un bâtiment hybride de
recherche de conception située à
versailles-satory le mobile à ben est un
projet pensé il ya trois ans l'idée
c'est vraiment de constituer ici et la
mort d'un cluster ca kloster c'est à
dire un lieu où se marient la créativité
et les idées d'acteurs différents
on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui l'innovation
elle a besoin justement de sortir du
cloisonnement trois acteurs sont
installés dans les locaux depuis
l'automne dernier les instituts vd comme
l'ip star et l'opérateur transdev
on est vraiment tous ensemble sur des
projets communs et surtout avec la
totalité des moyens à disposition de la
recherche des plus académiques jusqu à
l'expérimentation
ce qui est très bien aussi c'est qu'on a
un des pistes d'essai d'user l'autre
côté qui nous permettent de faire les
premiers tests des nouvelles
technologies avant de les déployer
nous travaillons aussi sur la la
convergence des sciences pour
l'ingénieur et des sciences humaines et
sociales
parce qu'il ne suffit pas d'avoir des
objets qui sont extraordinairement bien
conçu s'ils ne sont pas réellement
utilisés en toute sécurité
ce projet mais l'acteur public et privé
d'un coût d'environ 18 millions d'euros
le site a bénéficié de l'aide du
département et de l'agglomération
versailles grand parc
c'est dans ce département que
l'essentiel de la production aussi de la
conception automobile française se fait
pour nous c'est évident qu'il fallait
participer pour une intercommunalité 1
millions 6,7 ou même sommes
significatives
il fallait participer à ce grand projet
aujourd'hui 200 personnes travaillent
sur le site les premières recherches
concernent notamment les véhicules
électriques et leurs recharges